-Donald Trump arrived
in New York today
so that he could
be arraigned Tuesday
at the Manhattan
Criminal Courthouse
after a grand jury
voted to indict him,
making him the first
president in history
to face criminal charges.
And his allies on Fox
have been desperately
trying to dismiss the charges
as insignificant and biased,
while also claiming
they will make him a hero.
For more on this,
it's time for "A Closer Look."
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Well, by the time
you're seeing this,
Trump has almost
certainly arrived in New York
after being indicted.
News networks were showing
live coverage of his plane
taking off from Mar-a-Lago
like it was the [bleep]
space shuttle.
[ Laughter ]
This is all still very surreal.
I honestly never thought
I'd say the words,
"Donald Trump
has been indicted."
True story --
we've had that cue card ready
for seven years now.
[ Laughter and applause ]
It's so dusty,
I can barely read the words.
-[ Blowing ]
[ Laughter, cheers, applause ]
-Thank you, Wally.
[ Cheers and applause
continues ]
But, you guys, for me, this is
an especially big moment
because for seven years now,
people have been coming up to me
and telling me it's my fault
Donald Trump ran for president
because I made fun of him
at the 2011 White House
Correspondents Dinner.
And now today, I can finally
say my plan worked.
Goad him into running
for president,
during which time he will most
certainly commit at least one,
if not several, crimes
he will eventually be
investigated and indicted for.
Did I think it would be
for paying hush money
to a porn star?
I did.
Even kept the napkin
I wrote the plan on that night.
[ Laughter ]
So I guess the only question
now is, was it worth it?
Definitely not.
Long story short, I [bleep] up.
Now...
[ Laughter ]
I don't have to tell you,
this is earth-shattering news,
and it arrived at
an especially shocking moment.
Last week, after everyone
assumed the grand jury
had basically paused its work.
It was about to take
a long break.
The news was so shocking
that when Fox News
announced it on air,
if you listen closely,
there were audible gasps
inside the studio.
-We have just gotten word...
-[ Gasps ]
-...former president
Donald Trump has been indicted.
-Fox News was so unprepared
for this moment,
their studio basically turned
into the set from a telenovela.
[ Laughter ]
[ Gasps ]
Donald Trump has been indicted,
and he has an evil twin!
Ay, dios mío.
[ Laughter ]
[ Dramatic music plays ]
[ Gasps ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
Now, of course, Donald Trump
could never have an evil twin
because he is the evil twin.
He would have a twin who,
like, teaches kindergarten
and then...
[ Laughter ]
...delivers meals
to shut-ins on the weekend.
"We love the shut-ins,
don't we, folks?
Many people say,
"Why don't they go outside?"
and I say,
"It's right there in the name.
They're shut-in."
[ Laughter ]
But they'll never be shut out
if we keep them
in our thoughts.
And, look, I'm not saying
the news wasn't shocking.
It was. I walked off
my set last Thursday
after we taped our show,
saw the news alert on my phone,
and thought it was
an early April Fool's prank
from my friend Andy Samberg.
[ Laughter ]
And not only was
the news itself shocking,
but the details
that started to come out
about the possible charges
were even more shocking.
-Breaking news,
and it is historic.
Former president Donald J. Trump
has been indicted
by a New York grand jury
investigating hush-money
payments to adult-film-star
Stormy Daniels.
It is the first time
in American history
that a current
or former president
is facing criminal charges.
Learning from your reporting
that there's 34 counts
of falsification
of business documents.
Do you understand
that there are more
or possibly more --
different charges,
or is that, as you understand,
the totality of it?
-I believe that that is the
grand jury's work in this case.
Now, they could add
additional charges later
as other information comes up
with a superseding indictment.
But let's go on the premise
that 34 counts of anything
is a pretty complete
and thorough look at something.
-34 counts. That's insane.
Although knowing Trump,
it was probably 34 counts
of falsifying
the same business document
over and over.
"What should we say
the $130K to Michael Cohen
is for?"
"A legal retainer.
No, wait.
It was for
campaign advisory duties.
Scratch that.
Say he sold me a jetski.
Better still..."
[ Laughter ]
"...it was a down payment
for a new orphanage.
Hang on.
It was jetskis for orphans.
That's the one."
[ Laughter ]
34 counts.
I mean, if you throw
in the other cases
he's dealing with,
over the coup attempt
and the classified documents
he stole,
by the time we get
to the primaries next year,
Trump could be facing like
a thousand criminal charges,
which would be very funny.
We spent all this time
waiting for one criminal charge
and ended up getting
a ton of them all at once.
It's like when you turn
on a hose and nothing comes out,
then you realize
you've been standing on it
and you take your foot off
and you just get blasted
in the face.
[ Laughter ]
And, apparently,
Fox was not alone
in its surprise at the news.
Even Trump himself
seemed caught off guard.
In fact, he was apparently
so unprepared,
he didn't have a social-media
post ready to go,
as evidenced by the fact
that his first comment
about the news had a typo
in what I would call
a pretty important word.
-Moments after the indictment,
Trump went on a rant
on Truth Social, saying,
and I quote here,
"Thugs and radical left monsters
had indicated the 45th president
of the United States."
Yes, he meant indicted.
[ Laughter ]
-Or he meant indicated because
he thinks they're the same.
He thinks they just asked
the grand jury,
"Can you indicate if you think
this man paid off a porn star?"
and they all do this.
[ Laughter ]
Also, how did he not have
a pre-written social-media post
ready to go
for this eventuality?
This would be like
the British newspapers
not having an obituary ready
when the Queen died.
"She's dead!
Oh [bleep]
Uh..."
[ Laughter ]
"Uh, somebody google
what year she was born!
Oh!"
[ Laughter ]
"Who were her parents?!"
"Is her first name 'Queen'?"
[ Laughter ]
And yet, as shocked
as Trump and Fox seemed,
his allies in the GOP,
and in particular his two
oddly shaped adult sons,
seem especially taken aback.
They took to right-wing media
in full-blown hysterics,
raging against the indictments
to the point where it seemed
like they were all about
to break down sobbing
while also insisting
that Trump's enemies
were trying to destroy America
and the Trump
should essentially be allowed
to commit whatever crimes
he wants without consequences.
-They're trying
to smear the guy.
They're trying to take cases
that nobody else would take
and resurrect them.
This is literally legal voodoo.
-Let's be clear, folks.
This is...
like, communist-level [bleep]
This is stuff that would make
Mao, Stalin, Pol Pot,
it would make them blush.
-They see the weaponization
of politics
and of the justice system.
We've seen it with the FBI.
We've seen it with the DOJ.
We've seen it
time and time again.
At some point,
the guy deserves a pass.
-"At some point"?
[ Laughter ]
The guy's entire life
has been a pass!
It's like --
[ Laughter ]
It's like Trump
has an Olive Garden
Never Ending Pasta Pass
but for crime.
[ Laughter ]
He was accused
of racial discrimination
and violating
the Fair Housing Act
50 years ago.
He spent years engaged
in serial tax fraud
with the millions
he inherited from his father.
He bragged about
sexual assault on a bus,
he colluded
with one foreign country,
tried to extort
another foreign country
to help him cheat
in an election,
and he stared
at a [bleep] eclipse.
[ Laughter ]
And got away with it!
Your whole life,
people tell you not to stare
at an eclipse.
This dude does it, he's fine.
[ Laughter ]
Just fine. Walking around,
both eyes working great.
[ Laughter ]
Also, is it just me
or has Don Jr.
been watching "Succession"?
Because he has major
Kendall Roy energy in that clip.
[ Laughter ]
"I want this party to be
totally [bleep] revolutionary,
like communist type [bleep].
Let's get, like,
a Stalin impersonator
and maybe some [bleep] ketamine
or some [bleep]."
[ Laughter ]
"Blow [bleep] lines
with Pol Pot."
[ Laughter ]
Although Lindsey Graham
freaking out
is really my personal
favorite example,
given that he once
ferociously criticized Trump.
After the coup,
famously said, "Count me out."
Now Lindsey has flip-flopped
so radically once again,
he's calling the charges voodoo
and saying stuff like this
about how many counts
there supposedly are.
-If you've got a pile of crap
and you chop it up 34 times,
it's still a pile of crap.
It's "duplishus" charging.
-He's so enraged, he can't
even say the word "duplicitous."
He sounds like he's in
an episode of "Love is Blind,"
where they bring everyone back
and get 'em wasted.
"Irene is trying
to get with Paul.
She's being so duplishus."
Lindsay hasn't been this mad
since his memaw
made him go out back
and clean the barn.
[As Graham] "I don't care
if they're just chickens, Memaw.
If you chop up a pile of crap
34 times,
it's still a pile of crap!
I'm not cleaning up
this coop again
until you promise
to stop feeding
these chickens
your spicy jambalaya!
Chickens ain't
supposed to eat shrimp, Memaw!
It's unnatural!"
[ Laughter ]
It's just Monday.
It's just a monday, and
we're all having fun together.
Also, let's make something
very clear.
None of us, not me,
not Lindsey Graham,
have seen
the charging document yet.
We likely won't get that
until the arraignment tomorrow.
So we don't know
the exact charges yet.
But that hasn't stopped Trump's
allies from slamming them.
In yet another Fox appearance,
Eric Trump told a bizarre story
where he claimed he was
on a plane when the news broke
and that everyone around him
was on his side.
-I was on a plane.
I was on a commercial flight
when this whole
indictment broke.
People were coming up to me,
giving me hugs.
-Were they passengers
giving you hugs
or air marshals
tackling you to the ground?
"I was on a plane.
I got the news.
I tried to get in the cockpit
so I could get it to Mar-a-Lago
and see my daddy.
And then the people
were so great.
They were hugging me
and giving me
these wonderful
friendship bracelets."
Although, that was not
the weirdest thing
Eric Trump said on Fox.
He also tried to insist
that the Manhattan D.A.
was targeting his father
at the expense of other crimes,
although his story about the
supposed crimes kept changing.
-This is a city -- I've spent
a lot of time in New York --
that is falling apart.
I went into literally CVS
the other day,
and you can't buy Tylenol
because it's locked
behind these glass counters
because there's so much theft
and there's so much looting.
I went into Duane Reade
the other day,
and literally you can't buy
Advil in Duane Reade
without having somebody
come up with a key and unlock,
you know, those little
plastic things that you pick up
because there's so much looting
in the city.
-Usually when people go to
that many different pharmacies,
their name is Jesse Pinkman.
"Bad news, Mr. White!
The Sudafed is all locked up!"
Is it Tylenol at CVS
or Advil at Duane Reade?
Just pick a fake story
and stick with it.
"I went to CVS to buy Tylenol.
Then I went to Duane Reade
to buy Advil.
Then I went to Rite Aid
to buy Motrin.
And then I went to a Sunoco
to buy a Monster Energy drink.
And then I combined them all
and chugged it
so I could stay up for 72 hours
straight on Fox News.
That's why I sound like this!
Everybody in every one of
those places gave me a hug!"
But I also want
to address this notion
that indicting
a former president
is somehow communism
or antithetical to democracy --
another ridiculous
talking point Trump's goons
have been regurgitating
on Fox News the last few days.
In fact,
even the rest of the media
has been framing this story
as an unprecedented test
for American democracy.
CNN said, "There is nothing
in American history
that approaches the tumult of
the charging and possible trial
and conviction
of a former president."
Okay, first of all,
it's not "a former president."
It's this one.
You got to stop talking about
how a former president
being arrested is this crazy
and unprecedented act
without mentioning
that the guy was crazy
and unprecedented.
Until now, we mostly elected
career politicians.
And then for some reason,
we flipped out
and went for brain-damaged
casino greeter.
You don't get to be surprised
he turns up shady.
You know what I mean?
It's not like some
Illinois D.A. in 1848
was weighing
whether or not to charge
Abraham Lincoln for paying off
adult daguerreotype model
Breezy Candles.
And, yes, it may be true
that indicting
a former president
is a first
in American history,
but it's not a first
for functioning democracies.
In fact, it's the opposite.
Healthy democracies should be
capable of holding their leaders
accountable
for breaking the law.
And it's happened
many other times
in other functioning democracies
around the world.
Two former French presidents,
several South Korean presidents,
and two former presidents
of Taiwan
have all been convicted
in recent years
on charges
ranging from corruption
to bribery to embezzlement,
and even here in the U.S.,
politicians
who aren't presidents
get indicted routinely.
Let me offer as evidence
the entire state of New Jersey,
where, by law, you're not
allowed to run for office
until they pre-fit you
for an ankle monitor.
"We're not saying
you did anything.
We're just saying
you're probably gonna."
12 United States senators have
been indicted in our history.
Nixon's vice president
was charged with a felony.
And even in just one state,
Illinois,
four of the last ten governors
have spent time in prison,
including Rod Blagojevich,
who, of course,
was on Donald Trump's
reality show,
despite the fact
that Trump almost certainly
could not say his last name.
If Trump tried to say
Blagojevich's last name,
he'd probably end up
calling him Rod...
-Duplishus.
[ Laughter ]
-And if Trump World and Fox News
were caught off guard
by the indictment,
then I can only imagine
how unprepared they're
gonna be for the spectacle
we're about to witness tomorrow.
For the first time
in American history,
we're gonna see a former
president surrender himself
at a courthouse for booking.
-The Secret Service
is preparing
to bring the former president
to his court appearance
on Tuesday in Manhattan.
This is something
that they've been talking with
the New York Police Department,
the court security staff.
It's something they spent
days and days working out.
-People familiar
with this arraignment
are saying that they expect
it will be handled
like a regular arraignment.
He will still come in.
He will still be processed.
He will still be fingerprinted.
And he will go before this judge
and be asked to enter a plea
in this case.
-We understand
that he will get a mugshot,
he will get fingerprinted.
Whether he'll be
handcuffed, though,
that remains an open question.
-I wouldn't put cuffs on him
because he would definitely
try to wriggle his way out.
I'm pretty sure that's what he's
been practicing at his rallies
whenever they play "YMCA."
I mean, here we've been
making fun of the way he dances,
and he's just gonna be
boogieing away from the cops.
But it'll be especially
fascinating to see
how Trump handles his mugshot.
Trump's allies on Fox News
seem to think the mugshot
will actually help Trump.
And this just gives you
an idea of how desperate
they are to look
for an upside here.
Fox pundits
have actually been on air
claiming that Trump's mugshot
will make him look cool.
-This is a horrible night
for our republic
but politically a great night
for Donald Trump,
in that -- It just is.
[ Applause ]
Because -- No, no.
Because they're gonna --
You remember the mugshots
of Elvis and Frank Sinatra
and Johnny Cash and Jimi Hendrix
and Mick Jagger
turned them into even
bigger icons than they were?
If there's a mugshot
of Donald Trump,
it'll be in dorm rooms and
on T-shirts, making him a hero.
-Only thing --
Every person you mentioned...
a kick-ass musician.
Being a kick-ass musician
pairs well with crime.
Other jobs, less so.
I also think
the Johnny Cash mugshot is cool,
but if my dentist had one
of himself in his office,
I wouldn't like that.
And just a word of warning
to any college students.
If you put a poster of
Trump's mugshot on your wall,
congratulations on
never getting laid again.
Not -- Not because
of your politics,
but because nothing
would be more of a mood killer
than seeing Donald Trump's
sweaty grimace
while you're trying to get down
with someone you met
at a frat party.
I mean, imagine sneaking
into someone's pitch-black
dorm room at 3:00 a.m.
for a hookup,
and then they flick
on a lava lamp and you see this.
You'd be like, "Oh!
Oh, God. Ple--
Turn the light off, please!"
"Actually, if you don't mind,
I'd like to watch."
"Your po-- Your poster talks?!"
Trump and his allies
have been dismissing this case
as a bookkeeping charge
when in reality
it's so much more.
No one cares
about the affair itself,
and even the hush money is not
a crime if done correctly.
But Trump
secretly funneled money
through a fixer to silence
an adult-film actress
weeks before a presidential
election, and he lied about it.
He defrauded voters to become
the most powerful person
in the world.
And in a functioning democracy,
it's actually normal and healthy
to hold a president
accountable for that,
even if this is the first time
we've done it here in America.
And, look,
as I mentioned before,
I'm not saying this is all
worth it, because it wasn't,
although I will say when news of
Trump's indictment broke --
and this is a true story...
-People were coming up to me
giving me hugs.
-This has been "A Closer Look."